Es sind tatsächlich riesige Mengen Steine,
die auf dem Pazifik treiben, mehrere Millionen
Brocken aus vulkanischem Gestein.
Sie bilden eine Fläche von unglaublichen
150 Quadratkilometern - das ist tatsächlich
so groß wie Bochum oder Freiburg!
Und das vulkanische Gestein könnte auch zu
einer schlimmen Gefahr für das Ökosystem
werden!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, Abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Die vielen Millionen Brocken, die da im Pazifik
treiben, sind teilweise so groß wie Basketbälle.
Die NASA vermutet, dass sie Anfang August
beim Ausbruch eines unterirdischen Vulkans
entstanden sind.
Dieser liegt wohl in der Nähe des Inselstaates
Tonga und hat die Brocken bei einer Eruption
ausgespuckt.
Konkret handelt es sich um vulkanischen Bimsstein,
der entsteht, wenn die Lava durch Wasserdampf
und Kohlendioxid aufgeschäumt wird.
Bims ist grau und relativ leicht, sodass es
auf dem Wasser schwimmt.
Deswegen konnte es auch aufgespürt werden
und zwar durch zwei Segler: Larissa Brill
und ihr Freund Michael Hoult waren unterwegs
in Richtung der Fidschi-Insel, als sie vorübergehend
stecken blieben.
Dazu schreiben sie auf Facebook: “
"Das Feld aus Steinbrocken reichte so weit,
wie wir im Mondlicht und mit dem Licht unserer
Scheinwerfer sehen konnten."
Das vulkanische Gestein hatte also ihr Ruder
kurzzeitig blockiert, doch die beiden konnten
sich schnell aus der misslichen Lage befreien
und hielten dieses Erlebnis fest.
Und die Fotos lassen einen echt nur noch Staunen!
Der gigantische Gesteins-Teppich treibt derzeit
in Richtung Australien.
Forschungsteams hoffen, dass er eine Chance
für viele Meereslebewesen darstellt, da sie
in dem vulkanischen Gestein eine neue Heimat
finden könnten.
Vor allem Korallen könnten die Felsen als
eine Art Boot nutzen.
Dazu Scott Bryan von der Queensland University
of Technology im australischen Brisbane: “Wenn
einige von ihnen in unserem Great Barrier
Reef ein Zuhause finden können, hilft dies,
beschädigte Riffe zu erhalten und wieder
aufzufüllen”.
Sogar das “Great Barrier Reef” vor der
australischen Küste - die größte zusammenhängende
Ansammlung von mehr als 2900 einzelnen Korallenriffen
und UNESCO-Weltnaturerbe - könnte also im
besten Fall von dem Steinteppich profitieren.
Und diesem einzigartigen Ökosystem zu einer
größeren Artenvielfalt verhelfen.
Doch dies setzt voraus, dass sich die Brocken
weiterhin in Richtung der australischen Küste
bewegen.
Doch der Vulkan-Teppich birgt auch Risiken
für das Ökosystem, da so auch invasive Arten
eingeschleppt werden könnten.
Damit sind Tier- und Pflanzenarten gemeint,
die durch ihre Ausbreitung andere Arten, Lebensräume
oder Ökosysteme beeinträchtigen.
Auch diese Variante setzt allerdings voraus,
dass die aktuellen Berechnungen stimmen und
der Steinteppich seinen Kurs in Richtung Australien
fortsetzt.
Zunächst wird er sich Analysen zufolge an
Neukaledonien und Vanuatu vorbeibewegen, bis
dann die ersten Steine an der australischen
Küste ankommen könnten.
Dies wird - wenn überhaupt - in mehr als
einem halben Jahr der Fall sein;also etwa
im März 2020.
Steht das Great Barrier Reef vor dem Ende?
Anklicken, anschauen und unseren Schwesterkanal
Clixoom nature abonnieren!
Es ist für etwas wirklich Gutes.
Sei dabei und kämpfe mit uns für eine bessere
Welt!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!